hey everyone welcome to this video on
cyber security interview questions part
three
this video will focus on the various
operating systems and applications
related questions that can be asked in a
cyber security interview
our experienced instructor bipin will
take you through these questions
so let's get started but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from
simply learn the first question is on
virtual memory what exactly is virtual
memory
for a computer we have two types of
memory the first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory
which is also known as a volatile memory
and the secondary memory is your hard
disk where your data is stored
permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4gb memory
or a ram as in this scenario on your
screen it is going to replicate that
and is going to create another 4gb of
virtual memory on the hard disk
and it is going to use it in tandem
along with the ram
so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize
the 4gb of the virtual memory that is
created on the hard disk
and it is going to swap data from the
ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a page file or
a swap file
the next question is what are different
scheduling algorithms
now the context for this question is
you're talking about a profe
processor and you are talking about how
processes are going to be fed to the
processor and how the process is going
to treat these processes
so the first is first come first self so
the process which requests the cpu first
gets the cpu allocation first
now whenever there are processes that
are being run by different applications
they make requests for some cpu time now
in first
come first serve the first service or
the first process that is going to
request some processing time
will get that much allocated to them
they will run through the process first
and the next and the next and so on so
forth
the second one is the shortest job first
this is the process with the shortest
execution time for that process is
calculated
and that process is selected first for
the cpu
then there is priority scheduling this
scheduler selects the task to work as
per priority
so there would be some tasks that are
marked with high priority some would be
normal
and some would be low so based on this
high
normal or low priority uh all the
processes will be classified higher
priority will be dealt with
uh first then the normal and the least
priority
the fourth option is multiple level
queues where processors are assigned to
a queue based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
etc so it will be classified based on
the
attributes given to that particular
process and
multiple cues will be created and then
based on the attributes the processes
will be
processed by the cpu then shortest
remaining time the process will be
allocated to the task which is closest
to its completion
so or look at it this way the process
that will
take the least time to complete its
processing
would be chosen first and then the round
robin method
where each process comes in turn gets an
equal share of time
so if there are 10 processors each
process will be
allocated a certain amount of time after
which the next process will be processed
and so on so forth
and it will continue in a round robin
fashion till all the processes
get executed so in short
six different scheduling algorithms
depending on how you uh how the
operating system
deals with it
the next question is what are the steps
involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of an ethical
hacking question
you're looking at devices and for and
the interviewer
asks you uh what kind of steps are
involved
what are the activities that you would
do in hacking a server or a network
now there are no specific steps that you
would define
because every hack is going to be unique
but it has a hack can be classified in
five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always
always be the recognizance step also
known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets
that they want to attack so here you're
trying to get to know the victims so you
can launch specific attacks
towards them you want to identify what
operating system they are utilizing what
ip addresses mac addresses
the versions of the operating systems
and applications the patch levels
find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible
find out the information about the uh
person who's using those computers
so you can launch social engineering
attacks and so on so forth so
the first step is all about gathering
enough information
based on which you can launch further
attacks once you have that information
comes the second phase which is known as
the scanning phase
this is more of a technical phase so you
have in the first step you've got your
ip addresses domain names
maybe even network maps and you have
identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live devices and then you're going to
scan them for open ports
processors protocols services you're
going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities
or a certain set of security loopholes
that you can misuse once you have
identified those
you're going to the next step which is
the gaining access tape
in this you are actually going to
execute your attacks based on the
vulnerabilities that you have found
and you are either going to gain access
to that particular system by installing
a trojan
or destroy the system by installing a
virus or install a spyware or a
keylogger
whatever you wanted to achieve so in the
gaming access phase
you would have based on the knowledge
that you've gained in the first and the
second phase you're going to launch your
attacks and you're going to try to gain
access
to that particular device then the next
step is where you're going to maintain
that access now that you have hacked
into that device it is not necessary
that you will always be able to get
access to that device
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password
after a few days your attack is
worthless so what you're going to do
here is you're going to maintain your
access
so this is where it is assumed that you
want repeated access to that device and
thus you're going to install a keylogger
or a trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device
without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover your tracks
so whatever activity that you have done
so far will
have created logs and will have created
information
based on which the victim will come to
know that they have been compromised and
may be able to trace that activity back
to you
so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked
and to prevent them to discover who has
hacked them
you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity
you're going to hide the files that you
have created so you have installed a
trojan or a keylogger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered
you're going to hide processes that have
been created you're going to try to
hide all the activity that you have done
so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they haven't
compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server network
application or
any computing device you'll come across
the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network-based attack
where you're trying to capture uh
data package that that are being
transmitted over the network and then
you're going to analyze them
to see if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
bank details or any anything of that
sort now
these tools would also depend on which
operating system you're utilizing
for example msn sniffer would work on
microsoft uh
operating systems eater cab would be
based on linux and so on so forth so on
the screen you'll see six different
sniffing tools that work on different
operating systems
wireshark is something that is common
both on windows and linux
it is used to analyze network in detail
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across
in most of your ethical hacking
trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do data captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but it is also a
known troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and net network
administrators
to analyze any issues that may be going
on in the network
right so while the first tool you see on
the screen is wireshark
like we stated is available for windows
linux
as well then there is tcp dump which
again has the same capability of
wireshark but is a command line version
whereas wireshark also has a gui a
graphical user interface
tcp dump is available on linux
msn sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had msn messengers uh msn
messenger is no longer there
but microsoft does or did have a
microsoft message analyzer tool uh which
they have stopped development since 2015
but that's another tool that is specific
for microsoft operating systems from
microsoft
that can be installed together more
information then you've got eater cap
which is a tool to launch man in the
middle attacks
data capturing and is is essentially a
linux command line based
tool then d sniff is another password
and
network capturing tool which can help
you capture data packets
prominently a linux tool
same with eatery this is a graphical
tool which will allow you to capture
data
data traffics and map protocols and
identify which ip addresses have been
communicating with what
essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like
launching manual attacks or capturing
or having specific filters that will
help you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
moving on to the next question what is
an operating system
now this is a very difficult question to
answer because
uh we normally when we want to answer
this question we
start off with the functionality of an
operating system right
we try to describe what windows does or
what linux does or what mac os does
and then we are trying to figure out
what an operating system is in the first
place
but an operating system essentially as
the slide says
is a software program that provides a
platform for computer hardware
to communicate and operate with the
computer software so it is basically an
enabler for
human interaction with the hardware that
you have
if you take the operating system out of
the question
it's just some hardware which cannot
interact with you
but essentially when you have operating
system like microsoft windows or linux
or mac
you're essentially essentially
installing an instruction set
on that particular device which will
allow you to interact
and manipulate the hardware to do
whatever you want that hardware to do
right essentially when we talk about uh
drivers for your various devices like a
driver for your lan card or for your
sound card or your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards uh
for
a functionality right it allows us input
and output functions
uh for example the basic example you
open up microsoft office products like
microsoft word or excel
and you get a gui on the screen
which you can interact with you got a
keyboard and you type on that keyboard
and the computer knows what you're
typing
and reflects those actions on the screen
by showcasing it on that particular
excel file or a word file so how does
the computer know what to do or what
you're exactly
intending to do at this point in time it
is all the operating system
that is providing you all these services
analyzing what your inputs are
and then based on the programming it is
going to execute that and show it to you
on the screen
right some of the most common commonly
used operating system on microsoft
windows
you have them in desktop as well as
server variants
unix linux again linux as desktop
and servers you've got ubuntu and linux
red hat
and so on so forth and then you've got
mac os
for apple related components the next
question
what is the difference between micro
kernel and macro kernel
the first thing we need to know is what
is a kernel kernel
is the heart of the operating system
that allows that
input and output to happen it allows
those drivers to be
set up so that the hardware can interact
with the software
and we can then instruct the software
and the hardware both
to function in a particular manner so
there are two types of kernels micro
kernels and a macro kernel
micro kernel is something that we
normally use micro kernels are for
operating systems that use processors
directly handled by the processor
the micro kernel is very small in size
micro kernel is large because it
basically is the entire image of the
operating system
the execution for a micro kernel is slow
the micro kernel is going to be faster
because it is more evolved there's a lot
of programming involved
extendability microkernels are easy to
extend micro um
micro kernels are hard to extend as fast
security is concerned if a micro kernel
crashes it takes everything down with it
the entire
operating system is going to crash but
in case of a micro kernel
it is only that particular process that
is going to get affected
microkernel there is a lot of coding
involved
microkernel less coding is involved
examples of micro kernels would be
symbian oss
most popularly used on yesteryear phones
nokias if you remember those
uh qnx and so on so forth micro kernels
your linux or bsd operating systems
essentially use macro kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems
so as you can see on the screen five
types of operating systems
batched os distributed operating systems
time sharing multi-program
and real-time what are batched operating
systems the computer operator places the
jobs coming from input devices into
batches
so consider this not from a desktop
perspective but from a
server perspective where these devices
are used by
organizations to compute and to crunch
some processes that is going to make
some business sense out of it
so when there are multiple processes
coming in multiple jobs that are
going to be scheduled a batch os is
going to place these jobs
in batches and they're going to crunch
those based on the
inputs that have been given by these
operators distributed oss where there
are multiple computers
which are interconnected and are
communicating through networks
so in a corporate environment you don't
use one single computer to do everything
you've got a data center
and the data center will have a cluster
of servers where they're going to share
some resources
to crunch one particular task right so
that's where your distributed oss
come into the picture then you have time
sharing oss
where you are renting some type so time
sharing oss minimizes the response time
example
in today's world cloud right uh you go
on to the cloud
you have a virtual service over there uh
you schedule something
you showed you the job over there it is
it is executed
and for that time being that operating
system services your particular request
and provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example facebook
from a consumer's perspective could be a
time shared experience then
multi-programmed os the operating system
uses cpu scheduling
to separate jobs so you're scheduling
the cpu to
complete certain jobs in this particular
manner
and in real time os the operating system
gives maximum time to critical
operation so it identifies uh the
priority of these operations it knows
the high priority items the medium low
priority items and based on that
it is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between logical address
space and physical address space
now when you're looking at address
spaces this is where applications come
into the picture
and when you execute an application it
is going to
create a particular address in the
memory
where it is going to create a buffer to
store its own information so that it can
be
provided to the processor processed and
then can be returned back to the
application as an output
right so as far as definitions are
concerned
a logical address is generated during
running of an application
or a program a physical address is a
physical address
or a physical location on the memory
module itself
right visibility you can view a logical
address because it is programmed
into a computer so if i'm looking at c c
plus plus
and i'm using malloc or memory
allocation uh that's where the logical
address is going to be created where a
buffer is going to be created for that
program
and whatever the user input is going to
be it's going to be stored in that
buffer
but whereas physical addresses are
concerned this logical address
will be created on a physical store or a
physical
memory module which will have its own
addressing mechanism
thus you you can see the memory module
but you cannot see the specific address
on that particular memory module
but as far as a logical address is
concerned while you're programming or
you're debugging
the application it will show you the
logical address that has been created
the start point and the end point of the
logical address that has been created
for that particular program
and it can be shown in a debugging
environment
right address space logical and
physical address is physical like here
this case it's the memory module itself
you can access only the physical address
on that particular memory because
logical addresses can be viewed but you
cannot access them
physically generation the logical
addresses are generated by the cpu
during the processing time whereas
physical addresses are generated are
computed by the memory management unit
or the mmu that you have on your
computers
and as far as logical addresses they
will always be they are variable
whereas the physical address is always
going to be constant looking at the next
question
what is the difference between logical
address space and physical active space
so moving on from the previous question
to this
the logical address is a address created
by the cpu
for the processors that need to be
addressed and that can be stored as a
buffer
in the physical memory whereas the
physical memory itself
is going to be an address that is going
to be there on the physical part of that
memory
which is uh which is going to be
assigned to it by the
mmu then the next question discusses
uh shells so what shells are used in
linux now what is the shell
shell is the command line interface that
we utilize on a linux machine so
the terminal window as we call it is a
shell
and there are different variations of a
shell based on what linux operating
systems you are using
the desktop operating systems that you
use or the server operating systems and
real
in today's world that you're going to
use normally we'll always have a bash
shell which is the first shell that you
see on the screen known as a
bone again shell it is a default for
linux distribution
so as far as end consumers regular
consumers are concerned
it is always going to be a bash shell a
bone again shell that you're going to
utilize for scripting and
to execute regular commands but when it
comes to high level programming
or it comes to specialization tasks then
you've got the rest of these
shells that you can utilize for example
the ksh
known as a con shell is used for high
level programming
which supports associative arrays and
built-in operations the csh
or the c shell uh has different
functionality like spelling corrections
and drop controls
the zsh or the z shell provides unique
features like file generation
startup files and fish friendly
interactive shell which provides
features like auto suggestions and
configuration so all of these have
different functionalities
depending on what usage that you have
for that particular shell
the most common shell like i stated is
the bash shell that you'll always come
across
in your desktop linux operating systems
then looking at the next question what
are the process states in linux
now what is a process process is
basically a service that is running
for a particular application for an
application to function
right this process is going to direct
user input
to the processor process it get that
output back to the application
execute it and then show it onto the
graphical user interface
for the user so in linux there are five
states
for a process first is the redis phase
now in ready
in this state the process is created and
it is ready to run so it is waiting
uh it is waiting for input it's ready uh
the application is
executed the running is when the process
is being executed itself
blocked or wait is when user input is
being looked upon
so it's waiting for user input so that
it can do the processing
completed or terminated it has completed
its execution
or was terminated by the operating
system for some reason or the other so
this is where
things have uh the processing has been
completed
and then lasted state is zombie where
the process is terminated
but the process table still holds the
information uh maybe it is waiting for
the kill request before it gets
terminated
so these are the five states for a linux
process
to be in and with that we have come to
the end of the cyber security interview
questions part three on operating
systems and applications
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video
please ask away in the comments section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
tune in to simply learn to watch out for
more cyber security interview questions
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here